regardez la réaction c'est énorme mais
elle est folle cette réaction regardez
ils ont piégé leurs fans tes fans de big
show au lit mes chansons préférées c'est
ça être papa et est rentré chez vous
c'est quoi ce que tu as une chaise ou
j'aime bien parce qu'ils sont vraiment
proches des phones sont super attachant
et généreux avec les fans déçus sur les
réseaux et il n'est sans moi je les
trouve géniaux et est ce que tu es déjà
les voir en concert
mais on pense que j'ai pas eu l'occasion
moi je suis allé au zénith de paris au
zénith de rang et un concert nrj gratuit
à contiennent s'il était en face de toi
tu aimerais leur dire quoi
qu'ils continuent comme ça que
j'aimerais bien les voir en concert baby
cloué au lit ça rime avec bravo et merci
et c'est quelque chose que j'ai toujours
pensé c'est c'est très gentil tu te dis
ça vraiment super niveau je suis perdu
il nous a vus au rêve non
ça tue franchement c'est ma maman c'est
la famille gros bisous j'aidais mon
cochon merci merci merci beaucoup
d'épreuves on va prendre vos noms vous
venez au concert de mon bijou
[Applaudissements]